[Music]  Azir affair it's me  We Need to Talk yes I don't think we do  I assume this is about Armageddon yes  [Music]  how long have we been friends 6000 years  are you under there crawling crowing  hell are you playing as friends were not  friends we are an angel  and a demon we're on opposite side we're  on our side  it's up to me yes we have nothing  whatsoever in common I don't even like  you you do Armageddon is coming then  it's all over  no Morgan fascinating little restaurants  only no use of all all the bubble shops  there must be some way of stopping it we  have to work together at the end of the  world we're talking about  [Music]  it won't be the water and award  the rule to end every  why doomed well then welcome to the end  times  [Music]